America still has this very fluid sort
of working to middle and then middle to
upper class system I have bags of
friends in the US homeschooling their
kids paying tutors to come around to
school like it but they come from
backgrounds as poor as mine and yours
yeah but they don't have that sort of
glass ceiling rigid class structure
thing that plays on top of them I feel
it as well with me and I can't wait to
be a dad you know like when the time's
right for me but I think about that too
how am I going to be able to give the
challenges that I need to to my kids to
make them sufficiently resilient because
I know how much I value that in myself
yeah whilst not making their life
unnecessarily hard